So let me give you a really, really simple
example of a differentially private technique
for one task.
So suppose you have a big lecture hall filled
with 500 students or something, and you want
to know what fraction of them cheated on at
least one exam during their first year.
So you want to ask them about a behavior that's
not only embarrassing but probably a violation
of honor code.
And you could give them the following instructions
— it's, you know, going to give them a method
of plausible deniability, basically.
So the instructions are as follows: First,
flip a coin.
Don't tell me the outcome of the coin.
If the coin came up heads, answer the question
truthfully.
If the coin came up tails, flip another coin,
and if the second coin came up heads, say
yes and otherwise say no.
So you see that a student who never cheated
still has a one-quarter probability of saying, "I cheated."
And a student who cheated still has a one-quarter
probability of saying, "I didn't cheat."
And so you can gather up now these basically
randomized responses, but randomized with
a bias toward the truth.
Randomized responses to your query and you
do a little bit of reverse engineering and
you can get a close approximation to the true
fraction of students who cheated during — at
some point during their first year.
Assuming the follow the instructions correctly.
And that's called randomized response and
it's a technique that was developed in 1965
by Stanley Warner.
And differential privacy actually assigns
a formal measure of privacy lost there.
That's associated with the ratio of the probabilities
of producing, say, the answer of 'Yes' when
the truth is 'Yes,' versus when the truth
is 'No.'
And it turns out that differential privacy
will tell you this is the logarithm of three
differentially private.
That's our epsilon for that procedure.
You could make it more privacy protective
by increasing the chances that they will answer
randomly and decreasing the chances that they
answer truthfully by instead of staring with
a fair coin, starting with a coin that's biased
toward telling them to answer randomly.
And that — oddly this thing, randomized
response, is — fancy versions of it — what
is being used by Apple now in iOS 10 and also
by Google for certain things in the Chrome
browser.